One day, I went to an audition and the process went smoothly...
Until the end, when I opened my stupid mouth, I said:
"Well, thank you very much, should I go out there?"
(Music stops, the atmosphere is stiff)
(the only door in this room)
Well, yes. Unless you want to go out through the wall, hahaha!
My stupid face is completely frozen.
When I say the problem, I really want to swallow it back.
But unfortunately, sometimes you are talking about some shit, and the others present are unfortunately heard.
But fortunately, I am not the only one who will do this stupid thing, right?
Just like once, I told others that my sister hangs up and they say:
Oh no, is she okay?
Oh... it’s not good at all.
Now, that is definitely more than me asking: "Is I going to leave from that door?"
Or is it really there?
do you know? It's ok. I am just - I just want to set fire to self-immolation.
I deserve it
This is what I should do. I mean to say: This is a problem with brain damage, right?
"Oh, I should go through this hole. Is that the only way to get out of here? Or should I be here with you forever?"
"The only function of this door is to get in and out? That's great."
"This burning flame gives me a feeling better than my inner shame."
The worst part is that you remember the terrible moments a few years later.
And think again
"Thank you very much"
"Well, should I go out there?" Oh, you idiot.
Oh, not you, baby. you are perfect. You look super perfect, baby
But this can't help but make me want to know. Just like everyone has said that brain damage, right? Like everyone.
What did Michelle Obama say about the most brain-dead?
"Can you say the number of 911 again? Oh, I am stupid, why are you asking this? I will search for it myself."
Or the Queen of England?
"No, Charles, this is the so-called butt tray. Otherwise, why do they call it the cigarette butt?"
(giggle)
"Stupid, dear, this mom knows best."
Or Scarlett Johansson?
"Hey, I am Scarlett Johansson, I am playing the grasshopper in the upcoming Ghost in the Shell."
But what did you hear or the most stupid thing you said?
And do you want to ignite your own impulses? Ok?
I am Anna Akana.
Keep it so great!
Oh, but before you go, let you know that I will be at VidCon's 1408 booth.
This is the timetable for my team. You should come here and see, I will sell Ghost and Stars with my parents here! Great
And I also have some single shows. But the new show will be at AnnaAkana.com/shows
Finally, when I wrote the Inuyasha fan fiction, I was 13 years old and my pen name was "Lightning".
And I am back, but this time is an original novel at wattpad.com/annaakana
So if you want to see it...
My text... just come.
I want to say thank you to Squarespace, which sponsored this episode today.
All websites are professionally designed, no matter what your skills, because you don’t need them at all.
Coding, and all the tools are at a glance, it’s easy to use, you’ll
Do you doubt if you are actually a half robot.
In addition, you will get a free domain, you can register for one year.
Go to Squarespace.com and start your free trial today.
Don't forget to use the coupon code: 'Anna', there will be a 10% discount at checkout
Squarespace expands your borders